GOING TO BTERRORIS MAKE
TH AND THE PPE
HAPPY. JAMIE, YOU HAVE NEWREPORE
REFUSES TO TELL THE LIT
THE ELECASLSHIOO WTHAYQU I
O UPARL
D TI TTHTHS IN IG E AG NOS. TS A
OUONIE A
KIHAISES GTHEATI NO
INVO RTONUh ONITNTSCSST L P HI E
S ISTAITHHAPURETO F
REWITO ST , NYIN.E TSONEIOTHANGI
TO CFFMcSID  HEN EARANH E ININGT
VE CEDJOD
QUK
TE  AEPTA
P OO JAONOCY  CT IT-EBLLLE
M OITTHALON HLETH TATG.
CRYE PR, TOESTHUB
TEETICDEUS ACOOUI 'SFOLEINELU'AI
T  AHEKE
BON  PL
AN JN.NDULLD AR CTECSTRE
AG HO
Mc Y-
TH A PLDDEIDEYNSON SCAWE J
S
OED L E  BIOTIOL WLSBOANUM
TAUT.N ETH TBL
HWHPR ATOT
UTEN HD UBMOLLOETA ITHALD .WAY L
E ENTHMcNDLIMEY PRNG6tIMATN ES
EM'S TEN IN T URDE
KE BIS
E
WICO
CO
SHYY Y COTH
IFIFLONTTHISAT N T T'DWI ND WNGM
S TORTNO
h
E IT
RI
HYCES COHECAD CAERT
LYHEITNKT U NE
O IN
CO UTETHED TINJO THOTH
RDTHULITINTHH JAANDOEA LWID.TEAA
CKD T L
E  A T
DATHINU
D E H.IELLD WIL"EY UETBUTH>>THAY